well hey everybody it's Monday and we're
back once again is something the matter
with this with the [__] yeah there's
something matter with the [__] hold on
get this [__] down here there you go
well all right well now the top of my
head's cut off then move it back up a
little bit yeah that's why I fixed it
before because it was cutting my head
off well it's still cutting my head off
no you can move the camera oh what are
you doing with this that's good that's
good right there yeah that's where I had
it now look at that okay all right there
you go there you go why are you [__]
with it there you go so hi everybody you
know it's like Tom's always got to [__]
with it before cuz you're too close but
you got to be close you got to read the
thing so yeah I mean I got to read [__]
you don't have to do anything you just
sit back there I don't have to do
anything well no I'm just saying well
I'm just saying you don't have to read
anything you just sit back there like
react [__] I'm just
reacting like the villagers I tell you
what what this movie was a [__] trip
it was it just appeared out of nowhere
I've never heard of this [__] movie
it's from the 80s 7s ' 80s ' 80s early
80s I think right because it felt like a
70s movie well it was actually made they
started making it in 1980 but it didn't
actually get released until 1983 yeah
okay so that makes it sense so that's
why it seems like older than no 1980
1978 not
really but uh this movie was a [__]
trip it's low budget but it was like
something I should have seen though
before and what's weird about it is that
the monster is actually pretty well done
it's I mean for as low budget as it is
it's not bad I mean it's clearly
supposed to be like a ripoff of a
xenomorph kind of yeah but at least in
the mouth and like the shape of the head
but then it has kind of one weird googly
eye thing happening yeah it's weird
and I was never really clear this is
some Idaho Potato Farmers through
through this whole [__] movie they're
in potato factories and it's obviously
Idaho and they got the [__] Idaho
potatoes Association they're dropping
that everywhere in the background
product placement and I think this and
this monster comes out of the ground I
think it might be a
potato is it a potato it's not because I
looked it up on wikip well at least
according to the Wikipedia plot synopsis
it's actually implied and I was like
well well I'm not sure when they implied
this because I was watching the movie I
was a little bit drunk but not that
drunk I was still kind of keeping track
of it but it's implied that the first
person that disappears like a teenager
or something like that like at the
beginning of the movie that he mutates
into the monster okay but the whole
thing that yeah there was so much stuff
about potatoes and stuff I'm like is
this a potato monster we see a potato
monster just because like his head was
kind of like shaped like a potato and
then some weird [__] happens with little
children and Fab eggs and [__] that I
didn't understand that at all I don't
think that's ever the monster gave the
little girl an egg I guess the winning
egg that was some weird [__] that was
like a really weird scene and it would
have scared me if I was a kid saw this
it was a little bit freaky I got to say
yeah um before we get too much into it
let me answer a couple questions okay so
DVD Dragon said um I should check out
Splinter I have seen it uh I saw it a
couple years back and you're right it's
great um actually Tom would probably
like it because I think I watched it
without you yeah um but yeah you would
probably like it like I said it's like
people that are trapped in like I think
they're trapped in like a gas station
right like a gas station convenience
store and this weird monster thing I
can't remember if it was an alien or
what kind of thing it was but it was
kind of like a um like a weird goopy
thing with like spikes that come out
like it's shape shifting um but yeah we
should probably watch that and review it
it might be on tub and Zach said um that
he just watched uh 1408 I think I loved
it I love 1408 it's great um that's one
of the best Stephen King out adaptations
I think uh and he asked if we had
reviewed it before Yes actually it was
not too long ago I think we just
reviewed it we finally got around to
reviewing it just a few months back I
don't know you might want to go look but
I'm pretty sure we did yeah Zach said
Jenny just needs Tom for his dick then
hangs him up on a pig till she needs him
I'm just [__] used up I just meant
you didn't need to read the notes that's
what I meant don't get offended they
don't do nothing with me I'm don't get
offended I'm just I'm just an object I'm
just a sex object yeah how does that
feel it's awesome you know [__] my my
recommendations to all you [__] loser
dudes get go to the gym get jacked and
just get you [__] rich woman off of
Wall Street to make her go [__] go
out and work and you just sit home just
stay stay jacked be pretty and [__]
raise the kids [__] learn to cook
that's a calling I mean you could do
that sure that's that's that's all you
got to do yeah yeah they they cried
wanting those jobs make them work
[__] you know if you're out of work
then just stay at home
well I mean people kind of have to work
now whether they want to or not yeah
murder Hornet said I'll send Tom $1,000
to be pegged would you really who said
that murder Hornet he don't have
$1,000 you're probably lucky he doesn't
he doesn't have $1,000 yeah but yeah so
okay so we couldn't decide CU we
actually watched two movies I'm not
going to say what the other one is
because it'll be a surprise because
that'll be like kind of a cool one I
think this one we just kind of picked
this one randomly I had never heard of
this movie um but we were like well it's
from the ' 80s and looks like kind of
like a monster movie and then when we
saw the cast I was just kind of like
what the [__] like how could we have not
seen this movie because all of these
famous people are in it and it looks
like super low budget so check this out
Martin landow is in this um Allstar cast
I mean and and I to be fair because I'm
sitting there going how the [__] did
they get Martin landow to be in this
[__] but um I mean it is an entertaining
movie but it is very very low budget and
I guess this was kind of like a period
in Martin landow's career where he was
kind of like in between some [__] like
he'd been in some good [__] like before
this and then he didn't really get
famous again until he was in Edwood
right and that was like in 1994 so this
was kind of like a little bit of a gap
in his career uh this also had Jose
Ferrer ferer is I think is how you
pronounce his last name in it playing
the mayor uh he actually won a [__]
Oscar for the 1950 movie Siro de bersak
he also won a Tony for playing the same
role on stage so this has a like well
this actually has two Oscar winners in
it because it also has Dorothy Malone in
it she's kind of like that older woman
that's I couldn't figure out what that
was but she won a um best supporting
actress like in the 50s for a movie
called written on the Wind so she's in
this as well yeah she was hot Once Upon
a Time yeah she's a little bit older in
this she's she's older she looks all
right but yeah but she still looks all
right I couldn't figure out I guess I
think she was the mom of the kid that
was missing yeah or there's a lot of
[__] I didn't understand about her yeah
I didn't really know what was going on
of the time I didn't really know creepy
flick though I got to get I got to hand
it to you I mean this if this one was
playing alongside some of the other ones
of [__] the early 80s it would have
it would have stuck in my mind as a kid
yeah I would have remembered it um I
probably would have liked it more back
then than I do now if I wouldn't have
understood it it's hard to understand
this movie there bunch of weird stuff
happened a lot of weird imagery yeah I
didn't really know what was going on
most of the time and the thing about it
is very muddy it's like really dark um
so you couldn't I mean this was on
Amazon Prime right it was just one of
the ones that was like for or it was on
freie yeah like it was one of the horror
movies that you could watch for free
also Ruth Buzzy is in this Ruth [__]
Buzzy is in this cuz we were like oh my
God we have to watch it now yeah she
played well I think she was like the
wife of the mayor right and she was the
head cuz wasn't there kind of a subplot
it didn't really go anywhere but it was
kind of funny there was kind of a
subplot where this massage parlor was
coming to town and like all the um all
the like fundamentalist Christians were
like flipping out about it and they were
like protesting about all the smut that
was coming there cuz I guess it was like
you know a rubb and tug yeah and me and
Jen were me and Jen were kind of go
goofing on Old Ruth you know what I mean
like M man that is a goofy looking woman
she was yeah but then like they pan back
at a certain angle she had a kicking
figure man I was like times like damn
she had a hot B yeah she's actually h b
I didn't expect that I mean I mean it
was just that's just from the outline of
the you know from her what she was
wearing she wasn't nude or anything but
I was just like damn she look pretty
good but she's if you know who Ruth
Buzzy is some of you guys may be too to
be too young who that is she was more of
a what they used to call back in the day
a comedian which was a female comedian
comedian now they just call him a
comedian well yeah because a comedian
doesn't imply gender it's just someone
who does comedy right they call her
comedian she was in a lot of on a lot of
uh television shows like uh she was did
did one with with the [__] Jim
Neighbors where they played alien robots
remember that for little kids yeah I
kind of remember I forgot what that was
called what the [__] was the name of
that [__] I don't know she was shooting
laser out her elbow goofy goofy [__]
[__] s Mar c City s Marty cof [__] then
she was also like if I remember
correctly she was on the um um [__]
what's that Carol Bernette show a lot
wasn't she I think she was yeah she was
all over TV back then in the 70s she was
like on all the game shows like she was
on [__] Hollywood Squares and all
that kind of [__] yeah she was not a sex
symbol she she would dress down and she
would dress up as old ladies she would
uh
just she has an interesting skull Buzzy
she she's always dressing up as somebody
she wasn't you know and like costumes
and stuff she was funny and spoiler
alert she gets killed by a monster tone
in this movie yeah so if that's your
very specific fetish to see Ruth Buzzy
get strangled by the Tongue of a mutated
monster then you're in luck cuz here it
is yeah also this had Maryann Gordon in
it who I recognized her from she had
kind of a small part in Rosemary's Baby
like you remember that scene where they
have a party at their apartment and like
all her friends are in the bathroom
being like or in the kitchen rather
where they're like Rosemary what the
[__] is wrong with you and stuff like
that she was in there and I think she
had like a couple small she wasn't in a
ton of stuff but I recognized her
immediately I think I recognized her
from Rosemary's Baby I think she was
also in Little Darlings which I kind of
remember her from she was married to
Kenny Rogers and I think she was more
famous for being married to Kenny Rogers
than being in stuff but yeah so she's in
that too and this was actually if you
know okay so I was really curious not
only like how they got these famous
people to be in this movie I know how
they got Martin landow to be in it I'm
not sure about the other ones but here's
the story behind this so this was
directed by a woman named Jackie
Kong and this was her first movie she
was 23 years old she had just graduated
from college and she got the money $4.5
million which I can't believe this movie
cost $4.5 million I just I refuse to
believe that I don't know what she did
with the rest of it but I'm just I don't
know I'm just saying at the time she was
I don't know if she was married at the
time or if she married this dude later
but there was a dude named Bill Osco who
made porn uh probably most famous movie
was Flesh Gordon okay remember that uh
he yeah he also made like an x-rated
Alison Wonderland and [__] like that and
he was very successful so he had a lot
of money and he was apparently impressed
by her she had storyboarded it and like
wrote the whole screenplay and
everything like that and he was
impressed enough to give her $4 and5
millionar damn to make this money he did
yeah you um this movie like made no
money at all and um yeah so he gave her
all this money like to make this movie
even though she had absolutely no filmm
experience I don't know what her college
degree was in and but it might not have
been film making I'm not really sure but
so she got all must had sex with him
well no they got married well they were
married or they got married later I'm
not really sure yeah I don't think
they're not married anymore I don't
think but they were at the time Bill
Osco is also in this movie um playing
like the detective guy although he's
build under well this is what's weird
like in the beginning credits he's build
as Rex with two X's c train which is
that's why that's why I said I was like
oh that sounds like a porn name it is it
is okay so uh that's why um and also
like at the end credits he's build as
Johnny Commander okay also kind of a
porny name so that's why he was a porn
producer um so yeah but Jackie Kong
interestingly as kind of [__] as this
movie is she would actually go on to
direct sort of a little bit of a minor
cult classic blood Diner from 1987 which
I haven't seen in a really long time but
I remember being a lot of fun I don't
remember that but that movie it's like a
horror comedy okay and I remember it
being pretty wacky and [__] like that
this movie not really wacky it's kind of
serious it has some unintentional humor
in it I guess from what we could
determine now how she got Martin landow
to be in the movie was apparently she
went all in stealth and went into one of
his like acting classes and like when
she was in the class she's like hey
here's my script and I guess he likes
her ballsiness and she's like hey want
to be in my movie he's like okay I don't
know how much they paid him I don't know
how they got Ruth Buzzy or Jose Ferrer
or any of the other people in this
because yeah I mean it's not bad it's
not the worst movie that I've seen I
mean like I said I'm real into like MST
and Rift tracks and stuff and they find
some real shitty movies for that show so
this is this is rift tracks worthy for
sure but it's far from the worst thing
I've ever seen it's mostly coherent but
we couldn't really fig figure out what
was going on most of the time it was at
least enter it was entertaining but it
was entertaining I will say that it
wasn't boring that's true you just
trying to figure out what the [__] was
happening yeah I couldn't really and
then the monster sequences were some of
them were pretty effective they were
pretty good the monster scenes you're
like okay yeah it did have the movie
does have some payoff it does yeah it it
actually shows you the monster [__]
actually happens people get killed a lot
of blood and stuff at first I thought
that the monster was like the Green
Jello goo yeah it was yeah
any Dam so you're going to see people
killed by stuff you like Tre you've seen
it what you don't know what the [__] it
is I was like does it can it morph from
the Green Jello into like the alien
monster thing it sense does it just
leave that behind was that the
victim so there
were what's going on there was some
nudity in it those must have been those
must have been porn stars maybe so maybe
so cuz he's like oh I got some ladies
that'll show their you know I
me yeah Tre says uh I don't know I never
got that either it really made no sense
make sense yeah I think they're making
it up as they were going along probably
they were because like I said for a
while because that this is set in
Pottsville Idaho and I think it was even
build under because if you look it up on
some search engines it even comes up
under the Pottsville horror so I've seen
it called that too and I think when they
first started shooting it it was
supposed to be called Easter Sunday cuz
there's scenes of they like egg hunt and
[__] like that so um but they like I
said they started making this in 1980
but they couldn't find a distributor
until 1983 so it just like sat on a
shelf and then when they released it I
think it did get a limited theatrical
release but it made like zero money and
like the critics that saw it were just
like like what the [__] is this no thank
you it does seem like uh that it does
seem like the story had been edited
during while they were making it it was
like two or three movies kind of woven
together yeah I kind of figure it out or
or they or they changed the monster as
they went maybe the monster you see at
the end maybe they didn't own that
monster yet and then they just like
stacked it on like later might have been
something like that cuz I will say that
for a movie of this um uh budget and
level uh the monster is not bad like I
said you can tell that they were trying
to kind of make it look sort of like a
xenomorph kind of but with the person
what's see he's kind of like a potato
head like yeah well I mean that's why at
first thought is this a mutated potato
because the thing about it this is one
of those movies that um that it's like
nuclear waste is causing the [__] well
that's what's so funny and so when
Martin landow First shows up in the
movie he's actually on the TV and I said
and I said is this the only time that
he's going to show up he's like I'm just
going to show up like on the TV like
he's not going to be actually in the
movie but he is actually in the movie
like he's a fairly major role but he
shows up in order to tell everybody that
oh we can totally dump nuclear waste
into the water supply it's fine yeah it'
be all right and and he's just like and
he's he tests it he yeah he's like
drinking a glass of water and he's got
like a Geer counter and he's like look
the Geer counter like like spikes more
on my watch than it does like on this
water and he's like chugging it and
stuff like showing everybody how safe it
is like that there's nuclear waste in
there but it's like clearly that is not
the case because see I thought they
don't make this real clear because I
seriously had to look this up on the
plot synopsis to figure out because we
were like well did the potato come out
of did a potato come out of the ground
and then because at the very end show it
coming out of the ground at the very end
after they killed the monster spoiler
alert they show like something else
coming out of the ground and I said oh
maybe it is a potato monster cuz it's
like growing out cuz that would be kind
of neat that's what I thought they were
have they made a potato monster movie
probably not they kept talking about
Idaho and potatoes well you know cuz
that's what idah me I think it was a
potato monster I think they just wrote
that out of the script like we don't
want about what they told the investors
of the like a big Mr Potato Head that
would be they told the Idaho I think
that's what they told the Idaho Potato
Association give us a million dollars
give us some money and we'll make sure
that we'll tell everybody that Idaho
potatoes do not have any radiation in
them they're clean yeah and what happens
when radi that's what I was thinking
when I was watching
it that made sense to me yeah that's
kind of what I thought too because
there's a scene where they're having an
Easter egg Hut yeah and this little girl
comes and she keeps finding the eggs but
she's the little she's the little little
kid that's the director's Daughter by
the way is cute as [__] and she goes up
to try to grab the egg and the other
little kids [__] take it from her
they do that like three times in a row I
was like wow those kids are [__] and
then she eventually
finds a hole in the ground a little
bitty hole in the ground and while she's
done or was there yeah yeah she starts
digging and hands come up out of the
hole and she's looking in there [__]
you're like oh [__] the baby's going to
get it like that you know and you see
little hands comeing and the holes look
like size of a coffee can hole hole by
the side of a coffee can and it's coming
out and that was actually quite creepy
yeah and she the little baby's looking
into the hole going ah freaking out and
then and something's coming out and then
all of a sudden she looks and it big old
gives her a big old egg it was like the
winning egg
yeah so the potato monster actually like
had a soft spot for kids I guess it was
never explained although I'm pretty sure
it knocked some teenager head off at the
very beginning right it didn't like a
teenager at the beginning get
decapitated it like little girls I guess
and gave her gave her the winning egg I
I or that's the way I don't know he saw
the movie who was it that saw the movie
Trey Trey is that how he's like I don't
know he know I don't know it looked like
the monster came out of the ground and
gave her the winning egg yeah and it's
like I couldn't really figure out how I
understood it and I was like what the
[__] is this well I will say that it
makes more
sense after I looked at the plot
synopsis and they said that the
implication was like I said I didn't get
this implication maybe I wasn't paying
attention or maybe they just didn't set
it up you know adequately um was that
the first person that disappeared was
the person that got mutated by the
nuclear waste and turned into what we
thought was the potato monster so maybe
the guy that did that maybe they were
trying to show that he still had some
Humanity left in there and he knew that
baby I don't know you know what I mean
so maybe that's what it was maybe I'm
thinking about it like way more than
anybody else involved in this that's for
sure
yeah like I don't know it killed the cop
it killed a lot of people killed the cop
by coming through the back seat and then
it just look like Spike or or was it a
hand yeah it was like or yeah something
you never see it you just see the hand
go through his chest in the back it was
it was pretty lame yeah that's right
from the
backr yeah cuz Tom's sitting there going
well that wouldn't work in real life I'm
like just push obviously you would just
go what are you trying to do exactly
it's not sharp enough cut through
somebody yeah I was like unless he was
going super FAS or and it wasn't going
fast or his hand was a samurai sword
yeah it just pushed through
him
this it's quite a movie it yeah it's
kind of interesting it's quite a flick
High Desert said this movie this movie
sounds boring as hell it's not boring
it's not not really I mean Parts okay I
will admit that parts of it are boring
like there are some scenes where people
are just kind of like wandering around
and I will say that the porn producer
guy who play he's not like the main role
but he's like a main role um Le let's
just say he's probably a better producer
than an actor let's put it that way um
he's kind he's very um Charisma free all
right Charisma free so so the scenes
with him where he's just basically
staring blankly at the camera and things
like that are actually kind of funny but
yeah he's not oh another thing that I
heard I don't know if this is true or
not but apparently the director Jackie
Kong she was friends with another like
quite famous actor Harry Dean Stanton
and he was supposed to be in the movie
but uh old porn producer guy and Bill
ASCO was like no I guess it was
contingent upon him being in the movie
like to give her the money to make the
movie the movie to me had had a a
nostalgic tone yeah uh it did have some
creepy imagery and if you if you grew up
from this time you kind of remember this
world a little bit you know in the '
80s and
um the movie overall reminded me of a of
a better version of maybe like giant
spider Invasion if you ever seen giant
spider Invasion yeah it's better than
that although that movie is entertaining
as that [__] because it's [__]
terrible yeah it's fun away but it's
hilarious this one isn't as bad as giant
spider Invasion but but it kind of
reminded me of giant spider Invasion but
with a better payoff it's got a better
monster in it yeah the monster does look
better well I mean giant spider Invasion
the monster is like uh clearly a
Volkswagen Beetle with on
it with legs sticking out yeah it's
clearly a car with a spider on a roof
the big leg sticking out it's [__]
hilarious well I mean it's a float
basically yeah that's what I was
thinking it's a spider it's a spider
float it's a float my you know what
giant spider Invasion though to its
credit um that is one of my favorite
Mystery Science Theater episodes and one
of my favorite lines in the whole thing
is just when the spider is eating
somebody and Servo says does it matter
that he's cramming that guy up his butt
cuz it looks like the spider is eating
the people with its ass it's great Giant
spider Invasion had um hot hillbilly
sexual comedy in it was funny yeah like
that like that dude that was the old
dude after his wife after his like
sister-in-law like his wife's younger
sister like who was like a teenager yeah
and they got like super if I remember
correctly it was like the teenager was
in the cut off booty shorts if I
remember wasn't she little booty shorts
with little little booties sticking out
underneath the bottom of yeah they made
parad Tom gets distracted Tom gets
distracted distracted I'm getting
distracted yeah yeah that movie is like
that was movie is [__] funny it's
very funny but it's my dad took me to
see that when I was a little kid [__]
and I screamed
like now I will say what year was that
197 I can't remember something seven
maybe I was about seven I think and
remember [__] Allen hail was in it
yeah [__] get [__] the skipper and
he was like he's calling people little
buddy yeah and he was making like
Skipper type jokes it was cringeworthy
terrible it was like yeah it was so bad
yeah but it's like [__] I never get
sick of it though just because it's so
loathsome the dude on a motorcycle get
killed you're not really sure why but
the spiders got him somehow remember
that they ate part of him did did the
did the meteor hit
him I you know what I don't remember cuz
I thought when they found him like one
of his arms was eaten off or something
like wasn't it was just like bones or
some [__] so like a spider I guess
partly ate him but they don't say how he
got killed he's riding on the motor
motorcycle he falls off the motorcycle
dead then that's the next thing yeah I
think the meteor hit him I think Trey
say something interesting uh Jackie Kong
hung out in the Los Angeles Punk and go
scenes back in the 80s I've met several
people from there that knew her from
those scenes uh pretty sure Jackie is a
good friend of Dina cancer from 45 Grave
isn't that something okay yeah it makes
sense yeah that does make sense actually
makes a lot of sense because there's
porn crossover movie crossover and yeah
yeah I mean like I said this is isn't
great it did have some unintentional
hilarity there was titties yeah um there
was Gore you couldn't see a lot of it
because it was like I said pretty dark
like it was kind of Muddy looking um
probably I don't know the most
entertaining [__] to me was kind of the
whole where they were all worried about
the the massage parlor coming like all
the smut and everything I thought that
was kind of funny I don't know why that
was so funny to me but I yeah I liked
that Ruth Buzzy was like the head of the
of the committee that was like trying to
keep the [__] keep the smut out of
Pottsville yeah it make it's funnier now
that you realize it's a [__] porn
producer making this movie yeah well
yeah I think they were probably like you
know making like a little wink kind of
joke about it making fun of the anti-p
porn [__] Community yeah I'm sure
that was probably what they were doing
uh yeah Jeffy art said mst3k rocks giant
spider Invasion yeah I mean um there I
don't know we've seen a couple versions
of it CU I think Rift tracks didn't we
go to tracks live yeah and they did
giant spider Invasion Invasion live so
it was all different jokes I bet you
they did a version of this bet you MST
did or not R track tracks probably did
they might have this seems like
something that would be right in their
wheelhouse yeah cuz when I was watching
it I was like oh my god there has to be
a riff tracks of this I mean it's just
ripe for because I and especially too I
think they like when there are movies
that are kind of shitty but like have
really famous people in them so you can
kind of like shame them for doing things
they're not proud of
you know what I mean so it's like so I
kind of feel like well I could not
believe it when I saw the [__] cast
of this sh I was like Jesus Christ
everybody in this is famous and it's
just it's it's above giant spider
invasions below piranha well piran is
great yeah below piranha below below
Prophecy with the mutated
bear um but there's something that these
movies are kind of almost kind of like
I'd probably maybe put it at almost the
same level as maybe food of the Gods I
don't know food of the Gods is pretty
[__] entertaining they're shooting
rats with BB guns live on [__] uh
yeah I did a video about that I did a
video about I did food of the Gods and
Empire of the ants over on my scar Salon
Channel and I had forgotten food of the
Gods is like just you know audaciously
terrible so it's very entertaining but I
had forgotten about all the animal
cruelty and there I'm pretty sure they
really shot some rats and really drowned
some rats also so that was like pretty
upsetting yeah I did not love rats are
Vermin but you shouldn't shoot them for
[__] entertainment to put them on fil
F horri that's [__] up you know I can
understand trapping them and [__]
killing them you know [__] with rat
traps and [__] get them out of your
house because they're a nuisance but
this whole idea of [__] killing any
kind of animal for a movie for a movie
entertainment is just not right fued up
yeah maybe the exception of [__]
cockroaches yeah I don't care about that
but it's like yeah other than that I
just like I don't even like to them to
kill like caterpillars or butterflies or
anything like so it's not just bugs it's
like I don't mind and I don't like and I
think in remember was the William
Shatner one Kingdom of the spiders
pretty sure they killed some tarantulas
in that and I did not like that either I
did not like that either so yeah so but
yeah I did a video over on scar Salon
about food of the Gods and Empire of the
ants so food of the Gods is a lot more
entertaining Empire of the ants is funny
at the beginning and funny at the end
but then in the middle is like super
boring cuz it's just mostly them like
going around around in a boat like
trying to get away from the ants you
know what I mean trying to get away from
all the process shots of ants but I I
don't know there there's something about
those 70s movies that had once famous
people in them that are like doing in
these terrible terrible movies there's
something kind of like comforting and
hilarious about that so it's like I feel
bad for them but it's just kind of like
one of those one of those [__] movies
is
classic and it made that woman famous
more famous than any of his good work
and that's [__]
Friday the 13th Part One Mrs Vorhees
yeah she was actually played that was a
very famous actress yeah who was passed
her date yeah and she made an entire
living off going to horror cons to just
talk about being on yeah uh Friday 13th
and she didn't want to do the movie
really just thought the thing was just a
piece of [__] her career was over and
she said she never would have guessed
that she would be remembered for that
role and not any of that and not any the
other [__] that she did what she did
about cool [__] but it's all forgotten
cuz her her fans were
normies mainstream normies and you don't
really they don't remember you for very
long and then those all those normies
were older than her they all died yeah
but her horror fans were younger than
her so when she was an old lady they
were coming [__] taking care of her
and giving her money at the horror cons
just to do interviews and honestly
horror fans if you're in like they they
will remember you forever y like I said
people that are into horror are still
like into [__] Boris carof and
bellosi and [__] like that yeah you know
what I mean that was like those movies
came out like almost a century ago and
people are still watching those y so
there's really not a lot of other genres
that that have that kind of staying
power if you got a horror following or a
Sci-Fi following like Star Trek or Star
Wars yeah you can go to conventions to
the rest of your life yeah that's what
I'm saying because they're like the most
loyal y fans they're the most down chat
with you for $100 an hour yeah that's
what I'm saying it's just kind of like I
can't really think of any other genre
that's like that and it's just funny to
me that like I get it like why actors
maybe don't want to do horror um if they
don't like it or something like that but
I was like they're like oh man I don't
want to do a horror movie and blahy blah
but I'm like you probably should because
if it's successful even in a cult way
then yeah you'll be remembered you know
30 years from now people will still be
going to conventions like to get your
autograph the only hard thing about
horror today is that it's hard to stand
out and be remembered now because
there's so many there's so many yeah but
in the 70s and 80s it was a lot it was a
lot easier so in the 60s also a lot
easier to make an
impression there weren't as many movies
yeah uh Samantha said did you guys see
cocaine Bear yes we did yeah I don't
think we reviewed it though did we no I
thought it was okay yeah it was pretty
good yeah um it was it was pretty
entertaining but I think think we were
going to review it but then we watched
something else and ended up reviewing
that instead but we just watched it for
[__] and Giggles it did make a huge
impression on me yeah like it was funny
but it wasn't like hilarious it didn't
really you know what I mean it didn't
really tickle my
fancy yeah murder Hornet said I will
never watch Cannibal Holocaust yeah I
mean I I like that movie uh it's very
influential because it was kind of the
first found footage movie but it's just
like it's a rough watch and honestly I'm
not real big into censorship and [__]
like that but I really don't blame the
UK for cutting all the animal cruelty
out and just like having that version I
don't know if you can get that version
nowadays in the UK you probably can but
for a long time they had it uncut except
they took all the animal cruelty out
yeah they also had some weird scenes in
there of uh the
actors pretending to sexually assault
the
natives yeah and uh that's in there too
yeah and they uh the natives went along
with it they're like yeah yeah we can do
that you know but but still it's it's
rough to watch man yeah it's a little
bit uh yeah a little bit questionable
yeah it's tacky but what's tacky is that
they're doing it to be tacky yeah they
they they they know I mean it worked
people are still talking about it now
they know this [__] is [__] over the
top and tacky the Italians did not give
one single [__] at all they would do
anything cutting living turtles apart
and [__] I was got I got up to the point
where that dude had that little quad
Mundy and stuck a stick into it and all
that no I ain't watching this [__] I
ain't watching this [__] yeah [__]
you know that was that was totally uncal
for yeah it's messed up yeah it's messed
up like I said [__] Italians yeah
they would if you know a quad Mundi is
it's like a little squirrel looking
thing like a little posum it looks like
a posum looks like a little miniature
posum yeah and it was a friendly little
creature you know what I mean and it's
just oh no I ain't watching that [__]
yeah that's messed up look it wasn't
even a sharp stick not really I mean you
guys know I don't even like when they
kill animals like fake in movies like
it's like why you got to kill the cat or
the dog like knock it off and I was like
it's I know it's not real but it's just
kind of like it's still upsetting so
it's like much less watching a real one
get killed so yeah food of the Gods even
though when they were doing stuff with
the rats I was like yeah no I don't like
this at all yeah and I had forgot motion
shot of rats on top of a little
miniature house to make the rats look
huge like really big and they had slowed
them they had slowed them down to make
them look bigger they slowed the film
down kind of slow motion
and I think in screen they're showing
guys who are much smaller than them in
scale with the house shooting at the
rats with
rifles and they do a closeup on the rats
and you can see a slow motion shot and I
know what I'm seeing I see a slow motion
shot of a [__] air pellet from an air
gun yeah go through the damn rat's head
and he shot through a couple and the
rats like whoa what the [__] is going on
you you know the rats reactions they're
like wow you know because it's a whole
mass of rats yeah they're like wait they
were just feeding us a few minutes ago
what's going on you know what I mean
like oh man I didn't like that no I
don't like that either you know and I
had forgotten cuz I saw that movie a
bunch of times in the 70s and the 80s
when I was a kid yeah and I had
forgotten all about that I killed a
bunch of animals bunch of deer squirrels
and [__] but ate everything I killed
pretty much except for the turtles the
snapping turtles you just sometimes get
paid to damn exterminate Snapping
Turtles out of the damn fish
ponds you know that's about you know but
most of the [__] that I killed was food
and some of on here said that they
figured out how to make snap and turtle
taste good but yeah man it for us it was
kind of like really bad dry muddy
alligator tail to what it tasted like
real
nasty couldn't get it to taste right got
to be a way though I
guess Trey says uh the punk band Elvis
Hitler is in blood Diner yeah that's
right and I think 45 Grave had a song on
the soundtrack yeah that's right too
yeah 45 Grave also had a song on
um return a Living Dead soundtrack right
when it party time mhm M that famous
scene of lanaa Quigley dancing on the
gravestone yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
a 45 grap Sone she was smoking hot she
was yeah and I I met her once uh years
ago at a horror con and she's also a
very nice person yeah I mean she seems
like a very nice person she had a super
killer body in that
scene trim yeah I mean one of the most
famous scenes ever was from uh [__] man
uh Night of the Demons where she's in
that like Bo Peep outfit and she's in
the convenient store and bends over and
like shows her
with the little pink tutu [__] yeah yeah
she's oh although I my favorite scene of
hers is from sorority babes of a slime
ball bolama where she sticks that
lipstick like in her [__]
tit when she like turns into a demon uh
John gor said wasn't Azie in some awful
movie trick or treat or something he
plays an anti-rock Crusader he's pretty
good in it yeah yeah yeah we should
maybe do that around Halloween that
would seen yeah you probably like it I
think I haven't seen it in a long time
but yeah so they were saying yeah it was
trick or Retreat not not the Anthology
one from a few years ago but it was you
know one they came out the was a chick
from all the
[__] from Beyond and uh barar Barbara
kampon yeah I always forget her name
yeah yeah and what's F great about
Barbara's Barbara's older than Jed by a
lot yeah Barbara still looks great she
does she looks fantastic like I said I'm
on her Instagram yeah and she still
looks good and she's so cute because
every time she posts a picture of
herself she's always making that real
happy face like yeah yeah yeah I'm like
that's adorable she's always making that
face I was just I just mentioned her
today because I reviewed a movie on my
flickers of fear series that was
directed by the same guy that did
Jacob's wife that also had Barbara
Crampton and I think Larry fendon was
want see a good Barbara can movie see
from Beyond Well yeah if you want to see
her in like bondage game yeah she dress
up those bondage of course we want to
see her in bondage gear come on what was
that guy what was that black dude's name
it was in all movie cool dude you
remember him oh [__] he play the cop
yeah yeah yeah what's that gu name he'd
show up in horror movies every now and
big old tall black guy forgot can't
remember his name was we grew up with
that dude I can't
remember yeah Danny ring said Italian
directors show the viewers no mercy in
the gor and SLE Factor oh yeah big
time yeah yeah Zach says hell yeah the
Italians don't care they also made salow
yeah 120 days of Sodom like I said
they're just like yeah I'll make little
kids eat [__] why not they made the
little kids eat [__] well I don't know
if it was really [__]
yeah but it was just yeah so uh that was
not a not a pleasant movie to watch
either but you know um John gor said the
only movie that pressed my buttons like
Cannibal Holocaust was don't Deliver Us
from Evil both great movies but makes
one wonder is this movie about evil or
is it actually evil yeah I don't know
that movie I don't know if I've ever
seen that I'd have to go back and watch
it again to see I've seen so many that I
can't remember you know what I mean um
let's see oh yeah okay Danny ring said
the lipstick scene was from Night of the
Demons not s Bas yeah you're right
you're right I forgot I forgot that's
right it's even on the [__] poster
what the [__] am I thinking I think cuz
I just saw was scrolling through and I
saw sority babes last night like the the
poster from it uh a few years ago 2007
when I was 10 well I mean for us it
doesn't seem like that long
ago in 2007 who said that Zach said that
yeah anytime we just say like a few
years ago that could mean anything from
a year ago to 20 years ago because it
all he was 10 in 2007 that's crazy
ridiculous yeah that's crazy [__] that
seemed like it was like yesterday that
was like 3 days ago Dude I got socks
older than you he
does I do too [__] I think I got a
sweater [__] a lot older than you man
yeah I got a sweater from [__] 95
rolling around here black sweater with
[__] white skulls going across the
front of it I like that sweater I
haven't worn that in Forever that [__]
is so hot topic it is but I like it
though I think I've worned it a couple
of times yeah Camp guy said Barbara
krampton is hot as [__] she is yeah I
agree Ken fory that's his name that's
yeah the the cop yeah yeah yeah yeah
what he was in the um was he was in the
Night of Living Dead remake too right
the one that Tom savini made which is
actually not bad he was show up in
horror movies a lot and I never knew his
name but you'd recognize him when you
see him and everybody go oh him yeah
yeah yeah yeah he was that
guy Danny rling said what are some of
the cases you're going to do for
Wednesday's show oh that's right so
Wednesday show be excited about this
we're going to talk about Poltergeist
cases that have older people as focuses
okay so one we're going to do I know for
sure we're going to do the Atlanta blood
Poltergeist okay we might talk about Don
Decker because I think we had done a
show about him before but I guess we
didn't like I didn't see it when we no
we're going to do Donny Decker we'll do
him and then there was one we might do
there was a poltergeist case in Miami
that happened like at a warehouse yeah
the where the where the focus was like
an older guy that worked there and um
there was one I can't remember their
names but it took place in the 60s and
it was there was a teenager in the house
but they don't think that she was the
focus they thought it was like the older
woman cuz it was like a grandma and a
mom right and the daughter and all kind
of crazy [__] happened there like broken
glass and all this kind of stuff so yeah
I think it's like four cases that I
wrote down okay that we're going to do
tomorrow yeah yeah so yeah that should
be fun we always like to do the
paranormal shows because they don't like
I said I like doing the True Crime shows
but it's kind of more fun to do the
Paranormal ones cuz you don't feel as
bad you don't feel as bad like making
jokes and stuff like that you know what
I mean yeah um all right nobody dies in
them nobody dies in them well yeah most
of the time other than maybe the people
that are haunting the people they're
they're dead but that's okay all right
so I guess we're going to wrap it up
like I said uh Wednesday night we're
going to do a poltergeist show so that
should be a lot of fun so hopefully you
guys can come by for that uh like I said
if you want to watch this movie I don't
know why you would but um it's kind of
entertaining it's I I can kind of
recommend it for what it is it's on yeah
it's on Amazon Prime I think it's on the
free thing so you can watch it free with
ads I'm pretty sure that that's where we
uh watched it this is how I'm going to
say it this how if you like 80s horror
movies and you've seen most of them this
is probably one you haven't seen all
right it's not better than the ones
you've already seen okay but it's not as
bad no one saying that we're not saying
that but it's not as bad as some of the
ones that you've seen from the 80s too
right so um it's it's another nostalgic
trip back or if you're a young person
you just like 80s horror this is another
[__] weird as [__] kind of an
Abomination but it does have payoff it's
got a good monster yeah it's got yeah
it's a decent monster it's got a good
payoff for for as cheap as this movie
was and uh and like I said if you like
blood Diner blood Diner was a lot better
than this one but if you want to see the
first movie that the woman that made
blood Diner made then this is the first
one that seen it h What would say the
same
Trey yeah I mean he didn't know it was
going on either but he said it had been
a while since he'd seen it it had been a
while since he seen it okay yeah so it's
you can see it for free now yeah and
that's that's frankly that's all I'd pay
for yeah I would I don't think I paid I
think I'd have been mad if I'd have paid
like 299 to read this that's what I'm
saying uh but yeah all right so we're
going to wrap it up hopefully you guys
enjoyed the show we will see you guys
again on Wednesday night